вы не достигнете значительных успехов и
достижений на самодисциплине и воле
самодисциплина и Воля - это прямой путь
к выгоранию и депрессии Почему
самодисциплина и Воля настолько
переоценены Давайте сегодня поговорим об
этом почему важно это знать и понимать
что самодисциплина и Воля не гарантируют
успеха более того они скорее приведут к
гранью и депрессии Потому что люди Глядя
на
успешных людей неправильно трактуют
причины их успеха Они видят как успешный
человек каждый день занимается рутинные
операциями что-то делает Каждый день
что-то делает каждый день а он а не
нарушает график и так далее и люди
думают приписывают это качеством
самодисциплины и воли Они думают что
Только благодаря самодисциплине и воли
Этот человек достигает всего этого Он
заставляет себя он преодолевает себя и
так далее Потому что самодисциплина и
Воля у нас ассоциируется плотно с
преодолением с преодолением каких-то
препятствий барьеров борьбой и так далее
и очень часто многие люди которые не
могут добиться успеха они оправдывают
себя тем что ну у меня нет
самодисциплины У меня нет воли и так
далее как будто это такие какие-то
компоненты которые необходимы чтобы
достигать успеха так вот основное
заблуждение в том что люди Неправильно
трактуют Сам источник или будем горить
у на самом деле самодисциплина и Воля -
это краткосрочные механизмы это
механизмы краткосрочной концентрации
энергии на на одном каком-то деле вы не
можете постоянно жить в этом режиме вы
не можете долгие годы жить в этом режиме
два основных
способа работать делать регулярные
действия и работать в этом режиме это
первое заниматься любимым делом есть
ЕС любимым делом то вы достигаете успеха
не имея ни дисциплины ни воли Почему
Потому что само любимое дело
автоматически вам дают эти качества и
свойства такие как настойчивость
последовательность регулярность и второе
но не так много людей которые могут
найти своё любимое дело но основное
благодаря чему успешные люди достигают
успеха и богатые становятся богатыми это
то что они преврати достижение цели в
привычку то есть они не могут не достичь
своей цели у них это стало привычкой и
это у кого-то сформировалось с детства с
детства интуитивно большинство людей
успешных людей они интуитивно это делают
во-первых что они делают они не ставят
тех целей которые не будут делать А это
сильно отличает их от других людей
многие люди делают цель не связанную с
тем насколько она они будут это делать
или нет Есть тако хорошее правило
которое гласит никогда не начинайте то
что можете бросить И не бросайте то что
начали так вот успешные люди - это как
правило те люди которые никогда не
ставят тех целей которые они не будут
достигать Это первое Второе они никогда
не ставят целей которые дорожку к
которым они не видят то есть они сразу
но ставит промежуточную цель и её
декомпозировать на конкретные шаги таким
образом они сформировали у себя привычку
достижения целей как эта привычка
выглядит как она формируется привычка
формируется за счёт петли обратной связи
первое Вы должны вот в Казин философии
есть такое понятие Когда вы ставите
настолько маленькую цель что даже для
вас Она кажется смешной первое научите
себя так это прямо можно себя
тренировать ставите сначала маленькую
цель Почему нуж ставить нужно ставить
маленькую цель чтобы повысить
вероятность её достижения раз а
во-вторых чтобы действия по достижению
этой цели не вызывали у вас
психологического сопротивления и
дискомфорта вы ставите маленькую цель
потом делаете действие второе потом
достигаете результата третье Потом
обязательно себя вознаграждает поэтому
когда ставите цель Обязательно
прописывается что вам будет за это после
достижения результата То есть как вы
себя вознаградить к чему приводит это
приводит к тому что вы получаете
удовольствие от достижения
результата в результате растёт ваша
самооценка А когда растёт ваша
самооценка вы следующую цель ставите
чуть больше Повторяйте цикл вам всё
нравится ваша самооценка растёт и вы
ставите цель чуть
больше почему это важно Дело в том что
люди представляют дорогу к успеху как
дорогу полную препятствий барьеров
каких-то опасностей и так далее и
они думают что самодисциплина и Воля
помогает преодолевать эти препятствия то
есть Бороться перебарывать и так далее
на самом деле с кем они борются с кем
они борятся Вот давайте поймём кто ваш
враг так вот на самом деле они борются
со своим подсознанием Ведь именно ваше
подсознание включает
прокрастинацию лень и отвлекается на
различные факторы никак не связаны с
вашей целью почему так происходит потому
что ваше подсознание управляется вашим
мозгом рептильный мозгом которые
отвечает за который работает по принципу
А что мне с этого будет и в результате
Когда вы ставите цель
А ваш мозг ставит цель А ваше
подсознание эту цель не приняло то
вашему мозгу приходится бороться с
подсознанием подсознание не даёт энергию
А вам за счёт самодисциплины и воли
приходится её выдирать подсознание
отвлекает А вы должны концентрироваться
тратить энергию на концентрацию а
подсознание вас отвлекает от вашей цели
А почему он отвлекает от вашей цели
потому что ваше подсознание не видит
Смысла не видит для себя смысла в этой
цели А в чём подсознание видит смысл
подсознание как я говорил это то место
где живёт ваш эгоизм Оно всегда работает
по принципу отвечает на вопрос А что мне
с этого будет и когда человек чётко
понимает что мне с этого будет
подсознание разблокируется и перестаёт
сопротивляться И вам легко достигать
цели и вот когда вы делаете петлю
обратной связи то есть привычку
формируете привычку достижения целей вы
ставите сначала небольшую цель и
подсознанию говорите ну ваш мозг Говорит
дай чуть-чуть энергии поэтому цель не
должна вызывать сначала психологического
дискомфорта потом вы делаете действия
достигаете результата а потом
вознаграждает вознаградить себя достигли
какой-то цели сходите в спа
сходите в баню сходите в дорогой
ресторан на крайняк попейте кофе с
шоколадом но обязательно какой-то
вознаграждение должно быть чтобы ваше
подсознание зафиксировала что цель
действие результат всегда приводит меня
к удовольствиям всё это всегда
доставляет мне удовольствие и таким
образом у вас выработает вот эта
Привычка что цель - это всегда
удовольствие движение к цели - это
всегда удовольствие это не
это не Преодоление препятствий это
всегда удовольствие Наверняка у каждого
из вас ваше жизнь случалось такое что
какие-то дела Дела давались очень легко
какие-то цели А какие-то дела давались
очень сложно вот Напишите это в
комментариях интересно будет почитать и
вы увидите этот паттерн Каждый раз когда
вы вознаграждается себя за результат вам
хочется достигать следующей цели Каждый
раз когда вы боретесь
а то по сути вы всегда боретесь с самим
собой Вы боретесь со своим подсознанием
А кто победит в борьбе самим собой итог
известен ваш ум никогда не победит ваше
подсознание потому что подсознание
формировалось миллионы лет А ваш ум
формировался
буквально десятки сотни тысяч лет это
называемый неокортекс именно кора
головного мозга которая сформировалась
совсем недавно поэтому он называется Нео
новый кортек новая кора Поэтому при
достижении любой цели всегда помните что
все препятствия и барьеры существуют не
вовне они существуют в вашей голове в
вашем подсознании именно ваше
подсознание создаёт все препятствия и
барьеры именно ваше подсознание делает
действия сложными именно ваше
подсознание не даёт вам энергию и
мотивацию двигаться дальше И если вы
выстроить правильный процесс то вам не
будет необходимости в самодисциплине и
воле возможно Каждый зритель выпуска
сейчас задумывается Так видит интервью с
успешными спортсменами фигуристы тяжело
атлеты успешные выступающие там на
Олимпийских играх спортсмены и часто их
речь похожа Один в один что они многие
годы усердно пахали тренировались
посвятили всю жизнь этому и как-то среди
их слов не слышится ни у кого что они
работали занимались в лёгкости и в
принятии то есть Часто мы слышим от
успешных людей именно первую фразу что
это Дисциплина и система А как тут быть
вроде бы это как-то расходится в голове
сейчас у людей эти вот два образа очень
часто Когда вы слышите выступление
спортсменов знаменитостей артистов
певцов любых знаменитостей успешных
людей в их устах звучит что секрет их
успеха - это самодисциплина это Воля это
настойчивость и так далее Я считаю что
они неправильно трактуют свой Успех на
сам самом деле ни один из них не достиг
бы успеха в своём поприще если бы они не
любили то чем они занимаются Потому что
если они не любят то чем они занимаются
то первое же препятствие их выбит из
колеи потому что любовь к своему делу
приводит к тому что вы делаете всё
расслабленно на драйве в потоке А это
кратно увеличивает вашу эффективность и
когда они Изо дня в день ходят на
тренировки
они не насилуют себя они ходят туда
потому что им это нравится потому что
они любят это дело там же вся система
построена Так что они участвуют в
районном соревновании потом в областном
городском то есть на каждом этапе Они
получают результат вознаграждения в виде
медалей почёта Славы уважения на
районном уровне потом на городском
уровне потом на областном уровне и так
далее Таким образом у них вот эта
привычка достижения цели закрепляется
Они получают
удовольствие ле они не ставят
невыполнимых целей они если он чемпион
района он сразу не ставит цель что
следующая моя цель - это олимпийский
чемпион он трезво говорит он хочет быть
олимпийским чемпионом но при этом
следующую цель Он ставит стать городским
чемпионом потом областным чемпионом и
так далее поэтому петля обратной связи
работает всегда просто проблема в том
что успешные люди в том числе
неправильно трактуют источники своего
успеха каждый раз ког заставляете себя
что-то
сделать вы это делаете
формально вы это делаете без души без
души и без любви любое дело для того
чтобы был результат по сути что
происходит когда вы делаете что-то вы
трансформирует один вид энергии в другой
вид энергии вообще сам термин работа с
древнегреческого языка переводится
как потенциальная энергия то есть работа
по трансформации одного вида энергии в
другой то есть а я трактуют работа - это
действие по изменению реальности то есть
условно вот лежит поле вы взяли лопату
поработали теперь это вспаханное поле
реальность изменилась вот вспаханное
поле вы взяли картошку посадили теперь
это не просто поле это уже огород опять
реальность изменилась после этого
картошку она выросла дала там плоды это
уже огород это уже кормилец и таким
образом вы всё время трансформирует
реальность так вот работа - это способ
трансформации одной энергии в другой при
котором изменяется ваша реальность и для
того чтобы ваша реальность изменилась
для того чтобы вы вышли из той ситуации
в которой вы находитесь в другую более
лучшую ситуацию Для этого вам нужно
работать но работать нужно чётко
понимать во-первых а что делать
во-вторых Вы должны работать долго а для
того чтобы работать долго у вас должна
быть мотивация мотивация или стимул для
чего или от чего вы убегает либо к чему
вы стремитесь но теперь чтобы иметь
мотивацию и Стимул нужно обратиться к
источнику мотивации и стимула источником
мотивации и стимула является ваш
рептильный мозг то есть ваше подсознание
оно даёт команду от кого убегать и оно
даёт команду к чему стремиться и оно как
тот за вклад который держит ключи от
склада с энергией оно определяет Сколько
энергии под какую целью дать Под какую
цель дать А размер энергии который вы
получаете под какую-либо цель зависит от
тех выгод которые оно получит от этой
цели то есть от того смысла Недаром я
говорю смысл Это разница между
и потребностями которые вы
удовлетворяете так вот когда в каком-то
деле появляется смысл у вас тут же
появляется куча
энергии энергия всегда даётся под смысл
таким образом вы видите что для того
чтобы достигать любых успехов не
используя самодисциплину и волю вам
нужно чтобы любая цель имела для вас
смысл А для того чтобы любая цель для
вас имела смысл нужно две вещи первое
либо заниматься любимым делом оно
автоматически вам даёт смысл в виде
удовлетворения удовольствия и так далее
Либо второе а вы должны создать привычку
а достигать целей как это делать я
описал ранее этот и другие лайфхаки по
управлению мотивации по тому как
работает ваша психология в процессе
достижения целей а или то как
зарабатывать большие деньги Вы можете
узнать в моём Telegram канале Пройдите
по ссылке внизу поговорим там Y